you think back at all the Fed shares of
the past who do you think has been the
best well you know right now you have a
janitor's is you know sort of more of
the same and I have to tell you I I
often talk with two hats I for the last
couple of months I've been a politician
I've been in your world and previous to
that I've been a business person I've
always looked low interest rates as a
developer and I've always done very well
with low interest rates and I think that
frankly you know you look at what's
going on now the problem is I think
you're creating a bubble and the bubble
could explode I like Paul Volcker a lot
I thought he was a terrific guy in so
many different ways and he had he had a
good pulse if he had a good good you
know to me he had he was doing what had
to be done right now we have the low
rates again from the standpoint of what
I do in terms of real estate if I want
to develop i'm building the old post
office now i'm just finishing up Trump
national Doral in Miami from that
standpoint I like low interest rates
from the country standpoint I'm just not
sure it's a very good thing because I
really do believe we're creating a
bubble you said you like Paul Volcker do
you like the rule named after him as
part of dodd-frank the Volcker rule well
i'm not sure if he likes it but if he's
you know what honestly mark if he's
happy I'm happy he was a terrific guy
I've met him a few times and I thought
it was terrific but i think his his
policy and his demeanor it was something
very solid about him his demeanor were
very good